yeah black hole news we love black holes
don't we already so we're now seeing
behind one that's the cool thing about
this this latest results uh we've
actually looked behind a black hole
which is something you wouldn't think
you could normally do right because
black holes suck everything in don't
they so that's what we hear so how could
you actually see see behind one as a
team from stamford university they've
been looking at light echoes from a
particular black hole uh it's a black
hole in the galaxy called vicky one i
think it's 800 million light years away
it always blows my mind in astra in
astronomy right and when you're dealing
with black holes these a they're super
massive black holes so this has got a
mass of about 10 millions
times this mass of the sun right it's
just dealing with that it's a mere 800
million light years away
okay just just
so they'd be looking at this black hole
at the center of this galaxy and in
particular
what they've been looking at are things
called light echoes
now what is a light echo which is is the
first thing you would ask well you
essentially see a light echo the moment
you look in a mirror right i mean we
know what an echo is right if i do that
i could probably make an echo in here
let's do a sound okay
did that work yeah okay so what's
happening there obviously is the sound
wave is bouncing off probably the roof
or whatever right and coming back
because sound doesn't travel very
quickly we can detect the difference
okay when you look in a mirror
light's traveling so fast it's it's as
if everything's instantaneous right
but of course when you look at things on
vast astronomical scales then light
echoes can be it can be important you
can see sort of think light will bounce
off and it can there can be a
significant time difference before you
get the second signal so it's
essentially the same as the kind of echo
we just had in this room but we'd liked
and they're really useful for
astronomers because they allow them to
sort of map out regions that they
wouldn't otherwise they could get 3d
images of regions by looking at the
light from the echo so for example
there's a star called ylw
ones
i think
it's 400 light years away very young
start only about a million years old so
it's planetary disc is still forming
around it and astronomers try and look
at it right so they're using light
echoes to sort of study this now why
light echoes why are they useful well
because you look at this star sitting
there in the middle there's all these
planets starting to form in and around
it you've got the light that comes
straight from it well that's fine but
that's not going to tell you much about
the inner structure of what's going on
because you just sing one signal there
and the light coming from it but what
you can detect so you can imagine the
light going away from you bounce off all
this sort of protoplanetary disk and
then you get the echo back and you can
start to probe the inner structure of an
object like this which is which is what
astronomers are doing so what's going on
at the black hole so they're playing
around with light echoes right they can
map out the 3d structure you can get a
bit of a more idea of what's really
going on these supermassive black holes
have they're incredibly powerful right
and very massive and so when when gas is
collapsing onto it the gas heats up as
it collapses onto it you've got this
this disc of matter it's falling into
the black hole it's getting spun around
it's it's a real sort of vortex of
mayhem right
things are getting very energetic it
heats up so much that it actually
becomes a plasma so so the electrons in
the gas get stripped off because there's
so much energy associated with it
collapsing down onto the black hole and
so you now have this plasma this plasma
is a plasma of electrons and so it can
form a magnetic field as well and so
that what's going on is the black hole
this supermassive black hole is spinning
like this
and you've got these magnetic fields
being produced and these magnetic fields
go really high so they go
on all around the black hole they're
going up and because the black hole is
spinning and the magnetic fields are
sort of
binding into the into the core of the
black hole they twist
they twist to think of it like cosmic
strings twist around and chop off and
these do the same they twist and they
can chop so these magnetic fields are
there the magnetic fields are getting
torn and twisted occasionally they can
break and they can shoot these jets of
electrons essentially it forms this
corona and from there they can produce
you know the electrons come shooting off
this and they the x-rays are coming out
so this is what the strongest was
looking at looking at the x-rays being
emitted by these
these this corona
so this so this light echo we're talking
about today isn't actually an optical
light echo
yeah yeah so it's actually they're using
the xmln satellite which actually in a
previous life i i helped help build well
not help build but help test it so what
are those x-rays doing well the corona's
kind of we don't really know too much
about the shapes of coronas there's
still some debate about that about
whether they're big massive objects
above the you know like almost like a
lamppost type object above the black
hole so you've got the accretion disc
going right around like that and you
maybe have this corona up like this some
people say it's like that another idea
is that it's more it's a bit flatter
more of a sandwich shape don't really
know and that's actually one of the
things that we're trying to use these
light echoes to figure out
anyway whatever it's doing it's giving
off these x-rays and they're bouncing
off the the accretion disk and we're
detecting them like a stone skipping on
a pond effectively yeah you're there
okay you're the observer yeah i guess
you've got your telescope so
some of the x-rays come bouncing down
off the accretion disk of the black hole
and come straight to you x-ray comes
down bang hits the accretion disk we
detect it nothing fancy but that's
interesting you can get lots of cool
physics from that you can for example
detect whether the corona is changing in
size and for some stellar stellar mass
black holes we've seen that
um but it's everything's happening in
front of the black hole if you like but
others come this way now
they should just
go away right they shouldn't do it
there's no way these should sort of come
back this way you think it's going to
bounce off the of the accretion disc i'm
just going to go off it over there right
except they see the flashes of this slot
that have come straight to you but what
they've also seen is a
small time delay latex they see another
set of lower amplitude flashes
at a different color
and those they said it's corresponding
to the these flashes that are the x-rays
that have come down and bounced
off the accretionist at the back of the
black hole here is getting dragged
around the black hole through this
through how strong the gravity is the
space has been warped around here such
that the these can have a trajectory
which allowed them to come back round
to you so that's how they sing behind
the black hole general relativity
predicts that you should have this that
the space time can get warped
sufficiently
with a spinning black hole a geodesic is
called or a trajectory of a particle
will be one that can come back round
and that's the first time this has been
seen that's what they're particularly
excited about they're really able to
probe the structure not just in front of
the black hole but also behind it so
those x-rays are hitting the back of the
accretion disk from our perspective
being pulled back towards the black hole
but not into the black hole they're kind
of slingshotting around the back yeah
exactly yeah okay so so you see you
would expect that okay some stuff's just
going to fall back into the black hole
you're not going to see that obviously
unless you're suicidally jumping in
yourself there is a chance that some of
it will get dragged around and that's
what they've detected anything that goes
into the black hole can't get out so
it's sort of it's it's from the
accretion disk it goes all the way
around the black hole it's it's on the
other side of it and then comes around
and so you're getting information about
the back of the black hole but um in a
rather unusual way what's that
vindication of well i
see i i
i i think it's telling you that the the
general relativity looks like it's
correct at that but but that wasn't in
doubt yeah it wasn't in doubt but it's
nice to have yet another kind of
list of things that you can test gr with
it's not very easy to test general
relativity in very strong gravitational
fields there are not many places in our
universe where we can actually go and do
that this is one of them you know
a black hole and so it's a test of
strong gravity general relativity and
and so it's seen you know by as a
vindication and i was reading i read the
papers it's a bit too technical for me i
did i didn't understand you know the
observations that they were really
making and i do get the impression
there's a lot of modeling goes on i mean
how do you how do you model the the
photons that and the electrons coming in
and bouncing off and coming back round
but they say they're modeling which is
in the context of general relativity so
they're solving general relativity
equations with these trajectories in
them these particles in them
so that it's consistent with their model
and whether or not it's it's sort of
verifying gr and nothing else can can
can mimic it i i doubt
that i doubt i imagine that you can
mimic it with other things but
the fact that gr is working so well
still in this environment and the fact
that they're seeing this unusual
trajectory coming from the back
incredible observations i mean
incredible interpretation
the the raw numbers are just staggering
i they always blow me away 800 million
light years i mean
so that light was emitted 800 million
years ago
[Laughter]
and uh crazy that's what they're seeing
you think go back to eddington when he
saw that he measured the bending of
light around the sun with it with the
transit venus
and
this is now what we're talking about now
we're now talking about x-ray that's
being bound it's coming going off the
wrong side of a black hole and being
dragged back around and we're detecting
those now i think how far we've come in
in like 802 years
but that doesn't do it right because
that would actually make the the two
ends go the same way and so even if it
was kind of doing different things at
different times you might end up with
something s-shaped that way